una invitación que es señal de buen
momento entre ambas naciones Emmanuel
Llegará el martes por la noche a
Washington para un viaje de tres días
con mucha pompa Esta visita es la
segunda invitación que recibe desde 2018
cuando lo invitó Donald Trump esta será
la primera visita de estado de la
Administración biden Harris pondrá de
relieve la profunda y duradera relación
entre Estados Unidos y Francia nuestro
más antiguo Aliado que se basa en los
valores democráticos que compartimos los
vínculos económicos y la cooperación en
materia de defensa y seguridad la
cuestión económica estará en el centro
de las conversaciones la ley de
reducción de la inflación firmada por el
presidente biden preocupa a Europa que
denuncia el proteccionismo
estadounidense parece esperar limitar
las medidas destinadas a repatriar a
Estados Unidos las inversiones
industriales vinculadas con la
transición energética los temas
espaciales
similares también serán tratados la
última etapa del viaje será Nueva
Orleans la ciudad fundada por el francés
donde se hablara de la francofonía el
encuentro diplomático también contará
con una escena de estado de centenas de
personas en la cual participará la
delegación francesa compuesta por varios
ministros parlamentarios y
personalidades además de una acogida muy
especial se espera de este viaje que
Emanuel McQueen pueda hablar en nombre
de toda la Unión Europea